okay so I was wanting to do like Matt
Fraction run of Ironman that starts with
believe and goes through like the secret
origin attorney stark and like the
introduction of our nose stark and
different things like that but the more
I thought about it the more I realized a
lot of that comes out of Avengers vs.
x-men and then the more I thought about
Avengers vs. x-men the more I realized
that a lot of stuff comes out of
Avengers vs. x-men really everything
that leads up to like Secret Wars really
comes out of Avengers vs. x-men a lot of
the stories with characters are just
kind of you know wrapping up or you know
loose ends different things like that
but even within the story of Hickman's
Avengers a new Avengers for example the
animosity between Black Panther and
named where the Submariner is routed in
Avengers vs. x-men and so because of
that I was like well I mean wicked this
12 issues we can just do it in two
videos and then just call it a day so I
figured why not do a vendor's vs. x-men
you know I mean it's called Avengers vs.
x-men so so here's the deal really a lot
of this winds back all the way to a
house of an eagle Raptor if you see this
video hopefully this helps but those you
guys who don't know egoraptor who's part
of game groves had a big question about
what to read after a house of men with
regards to the x-men and Marvel did not
make it easy I mean they released like
seven different excellent publications
it was stupid but following the events
of house of M that story in and of
itself was just designed for the purpose
of really kind of reducing the mutant
population but what Marvel had under
their belt after that we're just like a
litany of different stories that writers
were creating and all this led up to
Avengers in there I just saw vengers vs.
x-men
and so there's like four main things
really with regards to the x-men
themselves because they're the main
focus here there's like four main things
that come out of this story the first is
Cyclops the second is Charles Xavier the
third is the mutant population and the
fourth is Hope Summers so starting with
hope she's really kind of like the big
picture character here after house of M
the mutant population was down to like
198 and it was really designed for the
purpose of just kind of offering some
measure of a clean slate which is to say
the mutant population had grown to be so
huge and so unruly that editor-in-chief
Joe Quesada was like let's just reduce
it down to an almost minuscule number
and then just kind of start over focus
on the core x-men that we have and then
just kind of grow it organically from
there the problem is that there were so
many events going on that Marvel never
really had a chance to sit down and let
the x-men breathe instead we got House
of M and then we were immediately
followed by civil war where
excellent were just hands-off and then
we were immediately followed by Secret
Invasion and the dark rain and then
siege and then for yourself and there
was all these stories that were going on
that Marvel never really had a chance to
let the x-men breathe properly because
they had to constantly roll them over
into these stories and so no one could
sit down and really do any great
storytelling with the x-men themselves
but there were a handful of stories that
are important there's really only three
that are really significant with the
character of Hope Summers the first is
Messiah Complex the second is Messiah
War and the third is Second Coming and
with these three stories what they did
is they basically introduced the
character of hope and Marvel II kind of
teased this idea of well you know Hope
Summers she might be the next Jean Grey
you know that kind of thing but the idea
was that she would be the host of the
Phoenix force but regardless whether she
was the host or not she was going to be
the way in which the new birth of
mutants began to crop up the problem is
that never really happened Marvel didn't
do anything with her character she just
kind of sat on the backburner for years
and years and years and years and it got
to the point there by the time Avengers
vs. x-men came around people were just
like why is hope Sommers still here now
with regards to Cyclops his character
had become more and more extreme over
the years and the reason why was because
again coming out of house of M Charles
Xavier was gone nobody knew where he
went to you know the Scarlet Witch said
no more mutants reality return to a
state of normalcy - the mutant
population you know being as large as it
was in Charles Xavier had vanished and
so in his absence Cyclops and Emma Frost
took over control of the x-men now
Professor X did come back in a story
called x-men deadly Genesis and that
introduced like Vulcan the third Summers
brothers so on and so forth but it
introduced a lot of a lot of the actions
that Charles Xavier done that he had
kept hidden over the years and the
result was that Cyclops and Emma Frost
more or less lost faith in him and so
they literally would not allow him to be
leader of the x-men instead they took
over and they said you could it be you
can be an advisor and that's it and so
Xavier just kind of sat on the back
burner and that was really it again the
other part of this being a mutant
population but it being so small the
idea was to bring it back somewhere
along the line to begin regrowing or I
guess you know restoring a mutant
population and so what the Vintage
versus x-men this really does a lot of
that especially once we get to the end
you know with regards to Charles Xavier
the Phoenix force that kind of a thing
but the crazy thing about this is that
the arrival of the Phoenix force it
really comes with the arrival of Nova of
Sam Alexander now the crazy thing about
the
is I want to say there was something
called there was a Marvel Infinite comic
which is basically like their digital
only series uh and it was really just
like Sam Alexander just trying to outrun
the Phoenix force as it was making its
way back to earth in order to warn the
Avengers really the superhero community
what was going to happen and ultimately
nobody could really you know he wasn't
able to make it in time and a Phoenix
more or less just kind of makes its
presence known now with regards to like
Tony Stark and Captain America becoming
aware of the fact that the Phoenix is
returning this is huge
and the reason why is because in the
eyes of them as well as virtually
anybody else who was there when Jean
Grey was the Phoenix their first thought
is whoever the host of the Phoenix force
is going to be is going to go awry now
through their own studies through their
involvement with the x-men and so on
they know the host of the Phoenix is
going to be Hope Summers and therein
lies the crux of Avengers vs. x-men it's
really just a battle for Hope Summers
it's making her as important as she's
ever going to be in the line of Marvel
Comics but with regards to their stance
on the Phoenix for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with this idea
and Marvel Comics the way it originally
played out is that Jean Grey was a
character that just no one really cared
about and the original x-men comic she
was quite literally the quintessential
damsel in distress she could never you
know get through training sessions on
her own Cyclops always had to rescue her
the team always had to step in to save
her life because she does never do
anything worthwhile when Chris Claremont
took over the x-men he was like that
depiction of that character sucks we're
going to make her cool and so because of
that they introduced the Phoenix force
Jean Grey became the Phoenix which gave
her just these godlike powers but the
idea was the longer the Phoenix hers as
Jean Grey the more the Phoenix began to
experience emotions anger rage love all
I kind of good stuff
and so because of that the Phoenix
became corrupted by emotion and in doing
so became the Dark Phoenix and so
because of you know because she was a
Dark Phoenix Jean or I guess the Phoenix
posing as Jean presented a credible
threat to not just earth but the
universe as a whole because remember the
Phoenix force represents the sum total
of all life that has and will ever exist
in the Marvel multiverse not just the
universe but the multiverse there's only
one Phoenix force throughout the
multiverse the Phoenix force will have
avatars like the Phoenix can break
itself off into pieces and then one
piece can appear in the alternate
universe one piece can appear in the
main Marvel Universe and one piece can
appear in another universe and different
things like that but there's only ever
one Phoenix force and so because of this
with hope being so young and being so
inexperienced
the initial
concern of Captain America and the
Avengers is that if the Phoenix takes
over her she's going to become the Dark
Phoenix it'll be the whole Jean Grey
saga all over again
and it's going to lead to absolute
pandemonium now the other half of this
equation is Cyclops himself now horse
Cyclops here when the Avengers show up
in the Avengers confront him it's really
kind of a funny scenario because on the
whole it's just the x-men against the
Avengers and really in the initial
skirmish of all this and once we
actually get to about the midway point
is when things start to change but
notice here you have guys like magneto
you have guys like Namor the Submariner
the reason why they're here is because
of the fact that during the events of
Dark Reign which was which followed
Secret Invasion when Tony Stark was
kicked out as director of shield and
Norman Osborn was put in this place
Norman Osborn started implementing a
campaign of world domination are really
kind of dominating the United States and
then intending to dominate the world but
he created groups like the Dark Avengers
like the dark x-men different things
like that which were basically
villainous versions of popular superhero
teams but the idea was that the x-men
would not play ball with Norman Osborn
and because Norman only had control of
the continental United States
they left the continental United States
and went to an island they called utopia
and so because of this the x-men were
joined by name of the Submariner who is
part mutant and rallied and stuff to his
conch alongside Magneto and a handful of
others who just saw Cyclops is a
legitimate leader of the x-men and we're
basically just kind of banding together
because there were so few of them left
it's really just circumstance they kind
of brought them all together but the
fact remains here the best reason why
they're here but with the x-men showing
up Cyclops the stance is that there's
only 200 of them left and Hope Summers
may be the key to returning the Avera
return into a mutant population back to
word should be it is to say you know a
whole new birth of mutants across the
world and so in cyclopses mind he's not
the bad guys here that's a crazy thing
he's the good guy fighting on the on
behalf of mutants who have yet to be
born who have yet to gain their powers
to have their X genes activated or
directions given to them and then
activated so of course this reads for
the most logical scenario when the
Avengers and the x-men just start
fighting one another now in truth
there's really not a lot to be had here
in terms of discussion I mean it's kind
of cool to see you know the Seavey's
these guys going against one another but
the ultimate goal is to get Hope Summers
out of here to get home summers to a
different location so that she can be
held safe away from the prying eyes of
the Avengers themselves and the safety
of the x-men but this is
really Marvel just kind of showcasing
the different abilities of the people
who are here I mean you know the
abilities of spider-man going against
some of the x-men so on and so forth but
it's also the idea that certain people
have to choose sides namely Wolverine
because remember following the Avengers
disassembled story Wolverine was rolled
over into the New Avengers team as it
was formed by Captain America Iron Man
alongside a Spider Man and a handful of
others and so at this particular point
and his characters chronology because
this takes place before the death of
Wolverine he serves as both an Avenger
and an x-men and so he's just kind of
having to pick a side now the funny
thing about this is that Marvel plays it
pretty fast and loose with his character
and has him walked both lines the coasts
of the Phoenix force gets to earth the
more Intune Hope Summers becomes with
the Phoenix forces power and so in a lot
of ways Wolverine having been in love
with Jean Grey sees very much of her in
Hope Summers especially the kind of
power she possesses the emotions she
displays if they get the better of her
from time to time and so we're hope some
errs basically just kind of
incapacitates everyone who's guarding
her and races off the other half of this
is that another Avengers team has been
sent into space in order to try to
confront and stop the Phoenix force
before it gets to earth now again this
is an impossible task the Phoenix force
is just wildly powerful it's way too
strong in fact the Phoenix force is so
powerful that Marvel has yet to define
an actual power set for the Phoenix the
Phoenix just has the ability to do
whatever the host wants to do at any
particular point in time that's
basically the power of the Phoenix I
mean the only real description we have
was given to us in Grant Morrison's new
x-men I think it was yeah new x-men was
just like the Phoenix just heals
universes or just like fixes problems
quote-unquote that's all it does like it
just does whatever it needs to do and so
it just has omniversal powers it's
insane what it is it is capable of as
well the idea of the Avengers trying to
stop it is absolutely nonsense but at
the end of the day we're Hope Summers
basically goes on the run
Wolverine actually catches up to her and
serves the purpose of essentially
helping her achieve her goal which is to
get to the moon and then in turn access
the Phoenix force now again the funny
thing about this is the idea that
Wolverines kind of picking and choosing
his allegiances I mean this initially
came out of a fight between him and
Captain America you know where Captain
America is beating the absolute hell out
of Wolverine Wolverine is beating the
absolute hell out of Captain America
it's kind of ironic this is a pretty
close fight because you wouldn't expect
to be especially with you know
Wolverines training in all these
different forms of martial arts and so
because of that it's kind of funny to
see this event unfold but when Wolverine
is effectively cast out he tracks down
Hope Summers and then helps her to get
to the moon now of course with regards
to this fight against the Phoenix it's
really like this Last Man Standing with
four Thor is really like the last of the
Avengers in space now the other Avengers
are dead I mean it very much alive it's
just they can't find any more because
they've more or less been incapacitated
but the funny thing about this is that
it's Marvel showing us where the Phoenix
force stands in relation to a lot of the
heroes that are out there because
remember for a lot of people Avengers
vs. x-men was their first exposure to
the Phoenix force they'd never read like
Phoenix in song you know they'd never
read any of the Jean Grey saga under
Chris Claremont I mean they never read
any of that stuff they've read about it
online but they never actually read the
stories and so because that scene the
Phoenix in full force is kind of
interesting but something that I want to
point out here is that as far as the
story goes Matt Fraction and really kind
of like nerf to the Phoenix like you've
made a pretty weak in comparison to how
it's actually supposed to be I mean
you're talking about a multiversal force
of pure omnipotence I mean it is
virtually unstoppable and so the kind of
things that we'll see playing out here
it's kind of ironic because a person in
full capacity of the Phoenix force which
is say the White Phoenix of the crown
can warp reality on a universal and
multiversal scale they could just
reformed anything as they wanted as they
want it to be which kind of begs the
question where does the Phoenix reside
in terms of all the powerful entities
that are out there and that's the video
for another time we did that once before
but we kind of have to change things up
since new characters have been
introduced and different things like
that but the fact remains here that with
regards to the Avengers trying to track
down host summers trying to find her
location all of them basically deduce
the fact that she's heading to the moon
you know where Wolverine is basically
helping her get to an advanced idea
mechanics tech station and then you
basically use a shuttle in order to get
to the moon once they get there this is
kind of like this major conflict this
final battle that takes place and the
crazy thing about this is that it's like
this last stand at the Alamo is this
last attempt to try to end the Phoenix
now the other half of this is Tony Stark
himself now once we get into Ironman
believe math fractions run this is the
point that they're they're basically
talking about when it comes to his
actions and destroying the Phoenix this
is really kind of what the what would
that race I never what they recall but
what that race is referring to stark
basically many men
patchers or develops a massive suit
designed for the purpose of effectively
destroying the Phoenix forces life
entity but even then that's why I say
the Phoenix force is so powerful because
it just represents life and so in truth
in order for the Phoenix force to truly
be destroyed
you would have to wipe out all things in
existence and then literally just like
wipe out the entirety of the multiverse
with not a single scrap of energy left
because if there's a single iota of
energy that energy will become space and
then it will become stars which in turn
will form planets which will grow life
and the Phoenix force will exist and so
because of that you literally have to
wipe out all things in existence which
can't really happen and so because of
that with the Phoenix force finally
emerging on the moon and making its
presence known to Hope Summers the
initial idea is that if it seizes
control of her again it'll send her into
a state of chaos because she's not
emotionally ready to harness the full
power of the Phoenix not even Jean Grey
was and she was a full-grown woman now
of course as time progressed with genes
character she was able to kind of
harness the Phoenix but she was nowhere
near as powerful as she was during the
original Phoenix saga it was more or
less like the Phoenix power would just
manifest occasionally but it was reduced
and strength by quite a bit
and so with Tony Stark basically
attacking this Phoenix ultimately what
it ends up doing is instead of
destroying the Phoenix force it splits
its energy into five pieces which go
into name with a submariner Emma Frost
Cyclops Colossus and magic Illyana
Rasputin a colossus little sister now
why these particular five were chosen I
have been I have not been able to find
an interview that it gives any real
measure of explanation it's just they
were the ones who were just there I mean
it's just really done for the sake of a
sake of storytelling but the cool thing
about this is it begs the question of
how bad are their motives or their
motives really that bad in the first
place because what we end up doing is
they actually pick up ten days after the
Phoenix five are basically formed and we
travel to the island of utopia now what
the Phoenix five have basically done is
to use their powers to transform utopia
into this utopia place now that's kind
of the irony of it is because of the
fact that with the namesake of utopia
when it was originally formed by the
x-men it was basically a utopia of sorts
that was designed to be kind of like a
modern-day version of Genosha and what I
mean here I know we're covering a lot of
x-men history here so bear with me but
Genosha was basically this place that
existed for the purpose of being mad
nito his own little home away from home
it was Magneto's place to basically have
a location where mutants could be free
from human oppression it was the country
that was governed by mutants that was
only for mutants now mutants could live
elsewhere in the world if they wanted to
but it was just one of those things
where you pay your money and take your
chances you live in New York folks are
going to hate you because you're a
mutant if you live in San Francisco
they're going to hate you because you're
a mutant if you live in Genosha you're
going to live among your own kind now
there's a whole backstory in terms of
why magneto got Genosha in the first
place and that kind of thing but Genosha
itself was destroyed in the first story
arc of Grant Morrison's new x-men that
was basically called es for extinction
and so because of that Genosha was just
this wasteland and so if you read like
House of M or really any of the modern
x-men stories before all new all
different Marvel and you basically go
and they show you the city of Genosha
that's why it's destroyed it was just
never rebuilt instead of rebuilding it
during the whole Dark Reign story Marvel
just introduced utopia and it was just
like cyclopses version of Genosha more
or less it was a safe haven for what was
left of the x-men now the fact remains
here that Charles Xavier is effectively
brought into the equation and this is
one of the most important parts of the
story and the reason why is because of
the fact that Cyclops is the first and
oldest student of Charles Xavier not
necessarily an age but he's the oldest
in terms of the people who have been
part of Charles Xavier life the longest
he was the first student he's the one
that really shared so many a big
Xavier's ideologies and that's one of
the reasons why there were some people
that loved Avengers vs. x-men and there
were some bit hated Avengers vs. x-men
that will get a little more into that
discussion once we get into the death of
Charles Xavier but the idea here is that
what Cyclops basically says is your
dream of a peaceful coexistence between
humans and mutants is exactly what I'm
bringing to you like you've always
wanted to see humans and mutants
existing you've always wanted to see the
world to be basically this giant utopia
that's exactly what we're doing here now
the problem with this is that Cyclops is
doing this at the edge of a gun he's
doing this with a weapon he's basically
20i gonna be heads of the heads of
everybody and saying if you don't do
what I tell you to I'm gonna pull the
trigger and so it's not really like our
utopia so much as it is just like an
enlightened monarch or an enlightened
dictatorship the funny thing about this
is that Hope Summers is being kept on
the island itself and hopes and I guess
they don't really hurt her kind of
offering to be here it's really more of
like hey you can be here if you want to
but you can leave anytime you want
to find out it's actually one of those
fake scenarios where she's really not
allowed to leave but again this one just
kind of shows the stance of Cyclops
because what he does is he approaches
her and says hey look the power of the
Phoenix force is so seductive you know
if I were to offer it to you what were
your answer and of course she says yes
now for Cyclops Yanks away and says but
you're not ready for it and this is the
contradictory nature of its character
with absolute power at least as they say
absolute power corrupts absolutely
that's exactly what's going on with
Cyclops right now as well as the other
Phoenix spot they're being overcome by
the power they possess and it makes
sense because it's like a drug I mean
imagine for imagine for example tomorrow
you woke up and realized that you could
warp reality that was enough time you
could you could train yourself to do
that so you could go to like Best Buy
and you could reach into your pocket and
have as much money as you needed at that
particular point in time or you could
just not even need money you could just
say you know I want a big 4k TV and you
just manifest it out of thin air imagine
you had that kind of godlike power would
you be willing to give it up would you
be willing to let it go of course not
I mean if you because you would
genuinely believe well I can keep it
contained I can keep it controlled I can
keep it from allowing the world to run
amok but you can't see the future you
don't know what's going to happen and it
may very well lead to the to the
destruction of yourself and everything
that you hold dear and that's really
what's kind of being played here with
regards to Cyclops is he's losing
himself in the power that he possesses
and that's why it's so extreme that's
why it's so intense is because of the
fact that Cyclops himself was ill again
the oldest student of Charles Xavier
he followed Charles Xavier ideologies of
a peaceful coexistence between humans
and mutants and the extreme he was the
one champion the one guy that Xavier
could always count on to uphold his
ideologies with Cyclops falling so far
so fast it's this idea that he's almost
reached the point that he's beyond hope
now he will reach that place he will
reach that level that he's basically
beyond any real measure of redemption
but what we end up doing here is we pick
up with the Avengers because again their
goal is to grab Hope Summers and their
goal is to get her out of there because
the stance of Cyclops and the other
Phoenix so I guess the other members of
the px5 is they're going to keep hope
summers on utopia they're going to train
her on how to use her powers effectively
so that when the time comes they will
imbue her with the Phoenix force and she
will become the new Phoenix and she'll
basically be a harbinger of the rebirth
and mutants across the earth well again
from the Avengers standpoint is only a
matter of time before she becomes
corrupted by
power and so what they do is they
basically initiate a halo jump now
halo jumps are kind of cool they've
seemed kind of interesting I've never
served in the military so I've never
done one before and I never would but
halo stands for high altitude low open
and what that means is you usually jump
from like 30,000 feet but the idea is to
jump from an extremely high altitude and
then open at the very moment before
really before you hit the bottom
relatively speaking so that no one knows
you're there and that's the idea to pull
off here now under normal circumstances
from what I understand with a halo jump
you usually attach flares to yourself
somewhere on your body like a foot or
hand or something like that so people
know where you are but in distances are
not doing that because if they did
anybody in Utopia would look up and say
hey what are those players doing falling
from the sky and they would realize the
Avengers are coming and so the funny
thing about this is that it's also the
Avengers not really under estimating but
just taking their chances as best they
can because Emma Frost is one of the
Phoenix Fire she's an omega-level
telepath she's wildly powerful in her
telepathic abilities you know with the
Phoenix powers she can read the minds of
everyone on earth at the same time
without being phased in any former
fashion and so she knows the Avengers
are coming she knows they're on their
way but something that I want you to
notice here it's how manipulative she's
going to become that's something I want
you to keep it back of your head because
she's going to become a very significant
and violent character but ultimately the
Cyclops and Emmas making their present
decisions kind of show up to confront
the Avengers but then the Avengers are
met with the arrival of the Scarlet
Witch now this is basically Marvel is
kind of reminding us Hey look the
Scarlet Witch is still pretty powerful
but it's more so fear than it is
legitimate power this gun of which is
more powerful as herself she's more
powerful than any one member of the
Phoenix pot but the Phoenix 5 are
terrified of the Scarlet Witch because
remember she's the one that said no more
mutants and stripped everybody of their
powers and so from from their
perspective she's terrifying
you know her power is extreme if she
could work reality and such a degree
that she can just remove mutant powers
from everyone then what could she do
against the Phoenix now the important
thing to keep in mind here is that the
Scarlet Witch has been reduced in power
she's not a house of M powerful anymore
that was a moment in time that was it
that was the absolute peak and height of
her powers at this point she's still
pretty strong in terms of what she can
do but against the entirety of the
Phoenix force combined into one she
doesn't stand a chance she's just not
that powerful feel really no one is and
so what we end up doing
here is of course the Scarlet Witch
effectively whisking Hope Summers away
and a-lying herself with the Avengers
what this does is it begins drawing
lines in the sand and this is marvel
effectively prepping the second part of
the story which is when a lot of the
x-men began to defect away from the
Phoenix 5 because of the aggressive and
the intense actions did they begin to
take towards the globe and everybody in
it as a whole but with that being said
guys we are going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come let's
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the rob port if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
in it peace
[Music]